[Applause]
oh i wanted to talk about my friend bud
munster he died
my friend bud munster died and bud is a
character from the show
he uh he's the uh my friend joe's father
he
um i've gotten two boating accidents
with him
uh we used to drink together and do
cocaine and take uh
pills and he died which is very sad
because he'd never stopped doing that
which is
not advisable but he was the coolest guy
and one of my favorite people in the
world and he's said some of the funniest
things that i've ever heard in my life
uh you know once his wife said to him
bud you should get he was like the fun
guy the party guy
we'd all go over to their house high
school parties and [ __ ] like that
um he'd take people out on his boat for
48 hours straight just drunk and throw
them in the water and watch them drown
and stuff
he was a good guy he loved freedom you
know people don't value freedom anymore
and you know these tick tocks
come and everyone else but bud uh you
know his wife said to him once his wife
goes why don't you get a [ __ ] job and
he looked at he goes what am i gonna
work
like some loser those are
memories that i really um i cherish he
was a good a great man and it was very
sad
he kind of i don't know if it was od i
think it was kind of a suicide yeah
and his kids were my friends are so dark
they are the darkest when i tell dan
story i mean this poor little kid's head
but i mean my friends are the darkest
he texted his family
uh my life of service is over let me get
the exact text
it's on my phone i wish i had it first
of all you didn't serve anyone so that's
kind of hilarious
like my life of service is over like he
never
did any for like anyone but he was fun
with me like we had fun
and that's important too so many people
forget that it's important have fun even
with people that are doing horrible
things
and he said um he said like my life of
service is over
and he said uh my earthly run whatever
he said he goes
he's over and his son had no idea he was
serious because he used to threaten us
all the time
so his son literally said this was the
last words he said his father his son
literally texted him
okay take care
and then he did it but that's so
[ __ ] bad that's so bad
to just end it like that [ __ ] bud
just where he goes they're all gonna
feel like a piece of [ __ ] now
i know that's what bud felt like right
at the end he goes you know what
they're all gonna feel like [ __ ] okay
take care oh i will take care
oh i will take care and you're gonna be
feeling pretty stupid but we're all
laughing
about it you know they want me to do the
eulogy and i do want to we might have to
cancel the show
i might have to fly down there and do
the eulogy because i've had so many fun
times with the guy he introduced me to
lisa's lounge
uh to to a place called the helm i spent
a decade of my life
in a crippling drug addiction and
financial ruin
and a lot of that was with him and
without that there's no podcast truly to
be honest with you
there's no podcast i would have went to
some [ __ ] liberal arts school
truly i would have been like i believe
in the future and hope
and i have a taint and whatever i would
major in like
i'd just be like [ __ ] i'd be a fat
activist
just like on the cover of a magazine
with my [ __ ] [ __ ]
out and i'd be living in vermont and
[ __ ] i'd be a full dyke i would have
transitioned to allez
i would have split my [ __ ] irish dick
out and just made it into a
fat [ __ ] fat french dip
and i narrowly
avoided that fate okay i could have came
out of the closet easier like when i was
younger and been happy
and like been financially stable and had
a good life
and man we would all not be here so one
of the reasons i didn't do that was
because bud monster showed me sometimes
it is more important
to go out and get drunk than to heal the
wounds of your childhood
you know what i mean sometimes in
cleveland you get this
sometimes that line of coke is more
important than seeing a shrink
sometimes that oxycontin is just what
you need you don't need to call an old
friend
do you understand sometimes being drunk
on a boat is just the best thing you can
do
at the time bud monster
was a guy that went with me every day to
a murder trial
that changed my life because after the
murder child i said i'm going to sober
up
i'm going to come out of the closet and
then i'm going to do stand-up comedy
but i was 25 years old i was the same
age as you literally you know
and uh bud came to the murder trial
every day with me because he was
unemployed
and he didn't have anything to do and he
loved murder
trials because they're really fun and
they're interesting and if you ever get
a chance to be a juror on a murder trial
do it not
one of these dumb things where like
somebody slips and falls into wendy's
and they're like i want 80 grand who
cares
but i mean i'm talking this was murder
torture rape the guy
uh stabbed her in each eye uh stabbed
her so many times
that the coroner didn't know uh how many
they had to stop at 65. he goes to flesh
is so bruised that at 65 times
we had to stop so what i'm trying to say
is this was well worth it you know like
this was a good
i mean you know it's it's it was a rough
experience for everyone her more so
i did a lot of sitting and judging which
is nice in a jury box you sit and judge
and i would crinkle chips you know as
the coroner was saying this i'd be like
i'd be like and there was a laceration
on each eye
and bud would be sitting in the back
they thought bud was a member of the
family they let blood in the sentencing
they let bud go into sentencing because
they thought but
every day bud would come to and then
after uh
we'd go to lunch every day and then
after the trial we'd drive home and get
drunk and then tell everyone at the
local bar
everything that was going on with the
truck we'd like update them we'd be like
oh they [ __ ] brought this expert in
and
whatever and [ __ ] you know and the guy
was really guilty i don't i'm
i'm not super sure about that but he was
like he looked weird
and he's in jail life plus 50 but
whatevs and
bud was a real big part of my life
because he was there
and uh we'd go to the trial every day
and uh then he went to sentencing we
went back for sentencing me and bud went
back for the sentencing the jury came
back there's like a big deal on long
island you could look it up
you know don't overturn it or in but uh
and then
bud went to the sensing and then we went
out afterwards a few days later we're on
his boat and we crashed into the piling
of a bridge
and we fell off the boat and then we're
like both bleeding and he looked at me
because you can't hang out with me
anymore and i said why
and he goes i'm trying to kill myself
like he said it very seriously
he's like i'm trying to kill myself and
then it hit me i'm like oh
he's trying to kill himself you know
what i mean
like this is not fun for him he's in the
depths of an addiction
but it was also a little fun but it was
like
you know and then i forgot what i said i
probably said okay take care but at the
end of it
i don't know what i said but and then
the last time i saw him was with you
yeah and and you had met him briefly i
did
yeah and what were your impression
it's not the most surprising thing yeah
you know like he didn't seem
super healthy you know yeah you ever
seen the movie adaptation
yes what was that actor chris cooper
michael cooper yeah chris cooper
this is a dan carney basic [ __ ]
simulation this is what he does
city academy award-winning film i know i
know
this is what dan kind of looks like have
you ever seen
[ __ ] american pie
you know stifler's mom yeah well
but no i know what do you kind of look
like him but like with
less ambition but it lived a life a
wildlife he had like
sold blow with like george young back in
the day he
he was hanging out in fort lauderdale
when it was like called fort leuderdale
because there were so many quaaludes
there he spent a lot of time in florida
uh you know it really didn't work
like rarely worked barely work didn't
really work didn't have jobs which i
always liked
i like people that don't work i think
they're fun
have you ever gone to someone's house a
tuesday at 11 a.m and they're there
there's something nice about that
right isn't there something nice when
someone's there at 11 a.m they'll just
like yeah if you want to do something
i'm like yeah
[ __ ] and let's do it you know i don't
want to deal with people that are like
well i got three meetings i got a four
o'clock i like it at 7 30. no
he was always home
uh he was a a special character you know
and it's sad that he um
is no longer with us but i guess in one
way it's good because i don't know what
the next
i don't know what like the back nine was
gonna be
like there was no shot that it was gonna
turn around
and be good you know he built a house in
georgia
that's like crazy it looks crazy it's
like
it's it's like literally like built like
a like a like
just like someone on drugs
built a house like that's literally what
it looks like like things are uneven and
walls don't make sense like it's
literally
like a [ __ ] maze so
but it is set i mean it's sad everyone's
dying
except my family how
how in god's name has my
family escaped
what has come for everyone you know
cleveland it's a it's an honor to to be
here you know this is a
real world-class
city
you may say hey a large percentage of
our population dresses in
reynold's wrap who cares
who cares many of our restaurants serve
fish which is actually just chicken or
fried bread
doesn't matter
matter it doesn't matter it's gonna turn
around i said i believe
i believe your time is coming you know
what i like i
truly truly believe
that cleveland like its best days are
ahead of them
but but
i also believe that about bud munster
thank you guys so much you're a lot of
fun thank you guys for coming out
we got a stand-up show you guys rock ben
avery dan carney follow these guys
thank you so much we really appreciate
it have a good night